he is running to end American democracy
as we know it is Joe Scarboro over on
the televised mental institution known
as MSNBC he's freaking out because the
polls are looking good for Trump and
Trump's a mean orange man he's not a
normal candidate he is running to end
American democracy as we know it he's an
authoritarian who a court uh in in
Colorado 2 days ago ruled that that he
led an Insurrection against the United
States government he is charged with
leading schemes to help overthrow the
United States government so so if they
want to frame it uh that way that's fine
if Donald Trump a candidate who supports
a new form of government here that's
authoritarian it's really that simple
and by the way Reverend Allen people go
oh you can't compare him to past Nazi
leaders you can't compare him to this
past Nazi leader or that past fascist
leader because he hasn't done that well
what hasn't he done he hasn't done the
things that the American judicial system
did not allow him to do last time but
may very well allow him to do this time
and if he has voted into office then a
lot of these people that are talking
about literal or figurative or whatever
the hell they're saying you're going to
look like idiots uh because he will do
he will get away with he will imprison
he will execute whoever he's allowed to
imprison execute uh uh uh uh drive from
the country ju just look at his past Joo
Joe take a chill pill man first off
you're not allowed to just randomly
imprison and execute people so
everything you're saying is completely
he will imprison and execute everyone
that he's allowed to imprison and
execute well you can't just imprison and
execute people for no reason reason I
know you guys would like to imprison him
for several sort of farsal reasons and
you would love to execute him right it
was who was it Congressman Dan Goldman
who just two or three days ago
congressman from New York who said that
we have to eliminate uh president Trump
he said that on your network by the way
I didn't hear you uh make any comments
about him um but it's all you guys get
it it's all just endless hysteria with
these people all they have nothing that
they can sell Biden on really although
we'll get to their comments on him in
just a second so it's just endless
hysteria oh my God Trump's starting to
pull well there's nothing cool about the
Democrats anymore the counterculture
thing and the Trump thing obviously is
picking up some kind of steam where it
just feels like it's moving a little
bit so he must be a fascist and he must
be a Nazi and everything else even
though it was you guys that were
colluding between the government and
Tech to silence him by the way there was
no Insurrection there was no plan to
take over the government and every it's
all